every once in a while I like to come
back to what is a really disturbing
reality in the United States which is
the tax exempt nature not only of sort
of like churches generally or of the
schools within churches but even radical
extremist dangerous churches having this
benefit from the government wherein they
do not pay taxes of many kinds including
sometimes taxes on the properties that
they own income taxes on proceeds
received etc etc etc and there is really
no better example of this than global
vision Bible Church in Tennessee where
if that sounds familiar we have talked
about it before where Pastor Greg Locke
recently went on an outrageous febrile
screed
uh where he said not only are there six
bona fide witches in our congregation
he said three of them are in the room
right now
okay this is this is sanctioned by the
state in the sense that it is a
tax-exempt Endeavor take a look at this
we got first
and last names of six witches
that are in our church and you know
what's strange three of you are in this
room right now right
three of you in the room right now
you better look in my eyeballs we ain't
afraid of you you stinking witch you
devil worshiping Satan is a witch this
is this is Dark Ages stuff
this is Dark Ages think about the track
record of the United States when it
comes to accusations of Witchcraft right
I mean there's there's precedent here
and this is reminiscent of a very very
bad time in Salem Massachusetts we cast
you out in the
Jesus Christ we break your spells we
break your curse we get your first name
we got your last name we even got an
address for one of you
now the address part should frighten all
of us because
um you know I mean listen you know you
don't need to think too far about what
is being threatened when you when you
say address now it's easy to write this
off as this is One Lunatic and of course
it is a lunatic but this is a tax-exempt
church
and he's making open threats here on you
know which witchcraft give me a break
guys
you so much is tough wrong and I'll
exposure in front of body on this tent
you stinking witch
you were sent to this church to destroy
us you were sent to this church to lure
Us in you were sent to this church to
cast spell listen some of you been sick
cause you befriended that witch
blaming but that's by the way this is a
this is a coveted crazy guy
um he called covet a fake pandemic in
December of 2020 he turned on Trump when
Trump started saying hey the vaccine's
pretty good completely turned on Trump
at that time so what he's even saying
there is those of you who think you got
coveted you have to understand the the
what this guy's talking about those of
you who believe you got coveted that you
you were sick you had symptoms it wasn't
covered it was witchcraft I love you in
my wife's latest Bible study and you
know who you are and we gonna ask you to
get out all that expose you in front of
everybody
we got all six of their names
all six of them
two of them had already been confirmed
for that thing ever even said it
first and last night this chick is new
to our church and don't know none of you
so you got a choice
you can leave with your spells all by
yourself
or I'll show up next Sunday
with a stage full of brooms and I'll
give you one and I'll fly your tail up
out of this place in the name of Jesus
for we ain't playing your spellcasted
witchcraft nonsense now of course you
know if we want to take this uh
pragmatically we would all be saying you
know if you're praying to Jesus the
right way isn't that stronger than the
Witchcraft like can't do you need to
kick them out to resist the Spells or
could you maybe just pray right and then
God will protect you from this who's
stronger The Witches it none of it makes
sense this is a guy who's running a
church with a transphobic homophobic
climate change denying covid denying
record he posted a video back in August
of 2020.
threatening violence against the Dunkin
Donuts employee who he referred to as
Nazi Skippy because the employee was
like hey we have a mask policy here
we you gotta you gotta wear a mask here
global vision Bible Church in Tennessee
tax exempt think about how backwards
this all is in the United States
if you're like me you love documentaries
and you should really check out our
sponsor curiositystream the only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries curiosity stream has a
better selection of documentaries than
Netflix Hulu and Amazon they always have
the newest and most critically acclaimed
titles including a bunch of stuff I
can't find anywhere else I just finished
watching fiddling it's about Bluegrass I
know so little about bluegrass it's
pretty fascinating and I watched a
documentary about it fidlin I've been
using curiosity stream for over a year I
always have it going on my TV in the
evenings you really can't run out of the
amazing content constantly adding new
stuff if you want a deep dive into a
thought-provoking new topic they have
documentaries if you just want to unwind
and turn your brain off they have
documentaries there as well right now
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off that comes out to just
14.99 a year a year that's just a dollar
25 a month go to
curiositystream.com Pacman the link is
down below